hello everybody my name is markiplier
have you ever been working one day and
you wanted to look up gratuitous amounts
of porn
well now you can simulate it because
what does give videogames
but the thing that can make you some
power I gotta put on my smartness then
let me just pull off my old Wow my thing
no don't that's not a good joke oh yes
hello hi how's it going have you ever
been working at an office in one day you
wanted to look up porn what hi how's it
going it's me
markiplier welcome to this game where am
I going away from this [ __ ] video
haha god this is the worst intro I've
ever done
ignore all the insanity that you just
saw welcome to NSFW
a game where you simulate working while
not working because not working involves
looking up porn so that's exactly what
we're gonna do and what the hell is the
fun scale equipped what does that mean I
get it equipped what is that a dick
flask why has it got a plus sign bye
what does that mean use I can't use it
email welcome oh it's a tutorial I'll do
this welcome to Andres utam flarin WETA
creative agency or your first day with
us please finish all of your training
videos oh I'll finish all my training
videos alright you can do it start to be
healthy and trust me you can manage this
stress in your life your only friend of
Marcel thanks as a proud Stefan I really
need that support how to use chery chery
is just like any other computer flick to
get that and click to get this thanks IT
department go suck 10 dicks which is
what I'm about to watch right click to
work or have fun
they're doing were looking at work no
find my pants being on doing work love
to work my work is we have received
substantial evidence that you have done
unethical act in the company we hereby
declare you fired not with love HR
department why can't I can't goddamn
hear them coming down the street
everyone can hear me coming down the
street but they I can't hear them cuz
too much porn noise because I'm not sure
what salutations fellow employee I've
been doing a project okay I'm walking
away yeah yeah a lot of fun 50/50 split
on work and fun what's the point of this
124 SGD I don't know what that means I
spend all my hard-earned money on buying
more porn click the heart I mean all
right SGD pizza good pizza Shades of low
whoa whoa hey shades of love oh oh we're
gonna get some good pizza
oh hell yeah okay avoid it let's do it
you can avoid it do not repeat your old
habit your trusty found Emily hey I got
a new friend
suck on that Marcel eat a dick Emily's
the new cool
alright dear Stefan I need you to color
the cow I sketched it is for the strong
pill ads why oh she okay
ah yes so maybe oh yeah don't mind the
moans [ __ ] yourself and go away I'm
looking at more pores oh baby yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah hell yeah I
upgraded my my porn looking and I gotta
do this again but this time I gotta get
way more of the porn this Stefan I hope
you're staying strong I know that you
can stick to the plan your straight
front Icha well I don't you each of my
balls okay I'm sorry that was a bad one
every other joke I made this letsplay
was great that one was bad I'm sorry
that crossed the line I have failed you
guys okay I apologize dear mr. Liam I
was asked to team up with you for this
project can you check the budget Sora oh
I love Kingdom Hearts let's play finally
make another goddamn game okay so I I
have exactly 248 SGD I can get shades of
love I don't know if I want that but
let's do it yeah okay spreadsheet ah
that was quick I mean not me I'm just
saying we're wrapping to get in here
[Music]
goddamnit
let me do my work in peace what are you
doing looking see you're not even doing
anything
[Music]
I didn't equip it Oh
catch me catch me looking at it please
catch me looking at oh oh how did you
manage to mess this up this is literally
such a simple concept you have like your
Stefan the staff the stallion excuse me
whoa
I saw what you did and I like what I see
I'm sorry but yeah I got you fired but I
had to protect my good name please meet
me later waiting eagerly swara now I've
got shades of love a quail not already
Jesum stop it you're so depressing wait
there's no noise murder that it's
completely silent I mean besides the
moan
yes making it Oh incredibly awkward I'm
pretty sure that was supposed to be some
sound accompaniment to that liquor sound
nowhere to be had it is super awkward oh
babe oh yeah oh yeah I know baby
Brad she trechie looking at the
spreadsheet bleh bleh now I gotta call
the hallway xx geez geez if I gotta go
all the way to the 20th this is gonna
take forever oh well hello dear player
there's oh it's done this is the end of
the NSFW alpha this game will have more
stories and mode will also have more
videos
press escape to exit sincerely game
designer well then I guess that's the
end of the game so that was actually
interesting I'm sorry that this let's
play was so inappropriate for everyone
watching not just because of the content
therein but because my humor is so
deadly that I don't think what I'm
trying to say is that I'm not funny but
at least you enjoyed the video maybe
hopefully so let me know what you
thought in the comments below and then
hopefully I'll see you in the next video
on but nothing you want to kind of just
bail on everything okay I'm gonna
skedaddle on out of here so see you guys
in the next and then like next let's
player that comes along see you guys
alright that was you by the way that was
you there anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching
[Music]